mais d'abord flou sur le déconfinement
il doit débuter dans une semaine sauf
que sauf que l'objectif dé 5004 qu'ovide
par jour est encore loin le premier
ministre jean castex doit donner des
indications après-demain dans 13
départements français le virus de baisse
plus augmentent exemple dans le loir et
cher où s'est rendue paul boyer
le taux d'incidence a augmenté la
semaine dernière et stagne encore
aujourd'hui y at il eu un relâchement à
blois certains l'affirment il ya quand
même des personnes qui font encore des
regroupements familiaux ou amicaux et je
pense que le problème vient surtout de
la passe que dans les magasins c'est
très bien respectée un étonnement sur le
marché le samedi le me dis souvent c'est
compliqué il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
monde et je trouve peut être même
beaucoup trop de monde c'est vrai que ça
reste un peu une contrainte quand même
dans la vie de tous les jours comme au
boulot et on a tendance à l'enlever
assez facilement alors qu'on devrait pas
le loir-et-cher est il un mauvais élève
pas plus qu'ailleurs en france répond la
rs qui pointent en revanche de nombreux
cluster dans les ehpad
aujourd'hui nous avons un peu plus de 80
cluster au niveau de la région centre
val de loire et un peu plus de 50 en
ehpad et c'est le loir-et-cher en effet
qu'il ya le plus de clusters au niveau
régional puisqu'il ya vingt cluster dans
le loir et cher il ya 15 de ces clusters
en est pas donc plus vous avez de
kloster plus vous allez tester des gens
éventuellement évidemment trouver des
personnes positives dont tous les taux
qui s'ensuivent sont liés à ces éléments
là cependant la tendance sur le long
terme est à la baisse le pic épidémique
est passé
en témoigne la baisse des personnes
admises en réanimation ces dernières
semaines seulement 3 en loir et cher